well of course president biden's
inauguration was yesterday one thing
people are still talking about
is how terrific everybody looked the
fashion world is
buzzing i mean check this out here's
vice president harris
in a custom piece from christopher john
rogers
and wow that is that is stunning yeah
apparently the designer used purple uh
to pay homage to the suffragette
movement
yeah no just beautiful so much thought
went into it
then the vice president's stepdaughter
wore
a crystal embellished uh mumu coat
check it out those clean lines paired
with the crystal detailing and it just
evokes hope
and progress it's perfect yeah
then of course uh bernie sanders wore
this
now it's a little bit of a different
direction i'm not sure
what he was trying to say with this look
andy any ideas
um no it's very enigmatic i know
well anyway i wanted to find out how
bernie sanders outfit came together
so hear this we were actually able to
contact the designer
who dressed bernie sanders for the
inauguration
that's right she's a salesperson at the
burlington coat factory
in essex vermont please welcome jen
finney hey jen
hi conan jen it's an honor to have you
here
tell us what was it like dressing
senator sanders
for this historic inauguration well
bernie shuffled
in the night before and went straight to
our base section
he told me he needed a coat because the
last one he bought was in 1978 for 22.
okay so you knew this was going to be a
challenge yes
and i love a challenge conan so i asked
him what are we going for here
and he said something i can also wear to
walk the dog
okay and what's the significance of the
color palette you chose
well i suggested navy blue but he wanted
something that would go well with
spilled coffee
he said imagine if oatmeal became a coat
okay so he had input yeah did you
discuss what fabric what type of cut
well bernie wanted something with
pockets because he needed somewhere to
put cough drops and loose tissues
oh this is fascinating uh-huh then i
said
bernie do you want a matching scarf and
he said who am i
jp morgan okay yeah he's got a sense of
humor
uh what designer did you end up choosing
the code is from dockers and the mittens
are gucci
i'm sorry his mittens are gucci donna
gucci
she teaches at the middle school
recently had a messy divorce
her fault oh okay that's too bad so
describe the first time you saw the
whole ensemble together
it was magic when bernie came out of the
dressing room
we all started crying we knew that was
the coat
then he said i also need socks and i
said two
aisles over next to the gel candles and
was bernie excited he said nothing in
scowled which from him
i'm told is a rave review but then i
mentioned that this particular coat
also doubles as a dog bed and his face
lit
oh wow wow what a historic moment for
fashion
hey conan my break's over and i really
need to go
okay bill yes right away my manager bill
is such an
[ __ ] i hate it here bye conan
all right well from the burlington coat
factory bernie sanders designer jen
finney we've got a great show tonight
rachel brosnahan
joining us we're going to have a great
i'm talking to conan o'reilly
it's o'brien conan o'brien no yeah he's
he's still on the air yes i'm very much
on the air
i don't know i guess it's a show it's
been a show for a lot no it's definitely
a show
it's been a show this is a web series no
this is a show that you know what i mean
rachel brosnahan when we come back
don't you have a coat to sell or
something they pretty much sell
themselves